we're talking about my amazing mom my
mom yeah yes my mom was the best the
best um and she was diagnosed there
there she is again she was diagnosed in
this is gay my mom was named gay
Matthews can you believe it gay and
gayer
Matthews she thought that was so
funny uh she was the best um and she was
diagnosed and she you know just thought
so so hard in such dignity and and went
into remission and and um and then in uh
2020 right before we met she passed away
my mother yeah and um I learned so much
being up close and personal with her
during this process it was so
heartbreaking uh but it also taught me
so much about strength um and family and
love you know